I'm ready I love so no never so with the
singing with Griffin this is Griffin
with the breath with the breath breath
all here and we flowin on the line like
like like like lightning I don't know
how to flow we saw one on the mic light
like like leather like I don't know how
to float welcome once again to Griffin
Griffin of Maine man everything Griffin
a podcasting blastin this after
Thanksgiving and I'm lasting
[ __ ] ain't fasting in a fat man
so big oh yeah
ladies and gentlemen you know I'm gonna
learn to rap one day just my man set
that new beat the only reason why I
didn't play the normal theme song is
because I'm sick and I can't do the
woo-hoos I try to do the rules but they
don't come out right Oh see I'm saying
the show must go on
you know I had a guest scheduled had a
conflict had to cancel and then the next
thing you know it's Thanksgiving and I
just and I was like how let me just push
it to another two just announced oh no
Reforma Griffin this week and I thought
no I can't do that I made a commitment I
do an episode once a week so here I am
it's actually Thanksgiving at 12:55 a.m.
so actually it's not thanks guys Friday
look at me I'm coughing I'm head
- Phoenix stand-up live so when this
comes out and you hear this an instant
to this and if you know Phoenix area you
can go to my shows tonight cuz this came
out on Saturday and I have shows
Saturday night
but here I am another episode of
Diff'rent with Griffin specials solo
episode and so I said let me talk about
what's going on tell you what my
Thanksgiving though I hope you all had a
great Thanksgiving I went to visit my
mom you know I talk about it a lot my
mom is she got dementia we had the
diagnosis it's like mild dementia
suddenly she's don't knows who I am and
all that kind of stuff her personality
is pretty much intact but you know it's
tough so I try to take pictures man I'm
coughing and stuff I'm so sorry guys but
anyway I try to take pictures so I got
this really great picture of her and I
they I'll put it right there I guess you
know and it was I was looking at it and
I got really emotional because I was
like damn I wish I had more pictures of
my mom and me I just like capturing all
these moments and it's just something I
never had done before so I'm trying to
do it now to get like so I can remember
these moments with her because I don't
know what's gonna happen like it could
get worse you know what I mean like all
of a sudden it could just deteriorate to
the point where she's like I don't she
thinks she's 12 or something like that
excuse me because dementia is a tough
disease like that I promise you I'm
gonna try not to cough a lot but anyway
I wake up early I go you know my parents
live way out in like Oxnard I live in
Los Angeles Culver City area so you know
I was like a you know you know drive out
there that it's raining the traffic was
terrible today the traffic was crazy so
like my GPS took me on some like weird
route so I went like PCH up north so it
was a nice Drive and we had a nice
little dinner at the retirement place
that they're at but here's the thing
though I got an electric car okay not
trying to floss I'm just telling you my
gas bill was so high because everybody I
care about lives 50 miles away from me
so just just just what it is and I go
every week and I'm driving
Hollywood every week to go to the Laugh
Factory hopefully that's the last coffee
I have to go to the Laugh Factory
in the Comedy Store and all that and you
know so I looked at my gas bill my gas
bill was something like $400 a month you
know and I was like this is just I got
like my hangover I can't no company you
guys hear about these mother that mother
[ __ ] every week there's a great candle
smells good it keeps it real tranquil in
here so my gas bill was so expensive I
was like I cannot keep doing this and I
was like I want to go green okay but
here's the problem
I got an electric car but I don't have
electric outlet in my building yet and
it's kind of like complex that I live in
I live in like this I condo thing
whatever and they don't have it yet but
they're good the guy told me he was
gonna get it but he hasn't got it yet so
I said well let me just get the car you
know I got the car I got a nice car it's
a nice car I said Jaguar
so I pace Jaguar landing over at a
Jaguar and off sunset I think they're
best I don't know if that's considered
Beverly Hills but anyway land and he was
great the guy to help me out anyways
shout out to him so I got the Jaguar the
[ __ ] the [ __ ] expensive
I mean you know you can look it up
yourself so I'm not trying to be like
you know whatever it is what it is I
saved my money I didn't buy a house and
all that kind of [ __ ] I got my money in
the bank I'm investing so I can
occasionally buy some good [ __ ] for
myself like clipper tickets or freaking
Jaguar but anyways I got the car okay so
up to this point I've had it for a month
it's been cool I know weird like I go to
the movies with my buddy Ben who was
supposed to be on but I got sick i'ma
have been on cuz he got his own podcast
now and Ben is just the weirdest
character he's such a weird dude I'm
gonna try to you know y'all don't like
people unless they famous but just dude
he's doing his thing and I might have
him on he's my buddy so that's all that
matters anyway so I couldn't get him on
to talk about you know whatever we were
gonna talk
but anyways I usually go to the movies
with him like once a week and they got a
charging thing there so you could charge
your car full while you're in the movies
but this was the first time I had like a
long adventure without having a full
charge so if my parents are like 50
miles away you know I had like a hundred
miles on the car so they got charging
they're free at their thing so I was
charging but I didn't charge it full so
I drove there with a hundred miles on my
you know availability and then I left
but only 80 so then I'm in Hollywood
with like 20 and I'm driving around
there doing my thing and then I get to
the comedy store with only like 10 or 15
left and now I'm like oh [ __ ] this is a
situation so then for some reason a car
jumped down from like 15 s like 5 so
then I had to freaking like pull over in
WeHo so I just tonight I had to pull
over a wee ho at the Ramada they got a
kitchen 24 right there and that's like
so I'm in there looking like because
it's like a super-gay area so everybody
in the place gay everybody that works
there is just pretty as gay boys and
they're looking at me like I'm some
weird old bear you know so I go in so I
have to sit there - literally the
waitress was cool so I told her I said
look my car so I was like you had like
an hour free parking but then I had to
plug the car into this thing and it
wasn't a fast charger so I didn't even
get enough I only got like it went from
five to like 19 miles after an hour so I
was like this is [ __ ] so then I get
back in the car and I'm looking on my
Mac because you got like there's like a
million apps there's like five or six
different apps to like charge the car so
I think I find a spot I look on a map
and it says that you can go to the
Department of Water and Power and they
got a free fast charger there so I get
to the place it's [ __ ] raining I
can't figure out it doesn't work it to
put a credit card or you test I kind of
account then there's a guy waiting cuz
you can only be there for 30 minutes and
that's all you really need at a fast
charger so this guy's looking at me like
I'm crazy he's not trying to help me so
then I have to leave and I end up at a
Chevron station on like
Olympic and like Sepulveda whatever that
somewhere over there finally get this
[ __ ] to work you know so I'm sitting
there now I'm sitting in my car it's
late this was tonight dude this was like
earlier so you know I'm sitting in my
car listening to audiobooks and I'm
thinking myself damn is this an electric
car [ __ ] worth it this is a lot and then
I like walked going to the Chevron to
get some water and as I go homeless dude
outside and the homeless problem in LA
is like I don't know what's going on
like oh we got to do something I just I
don't know how to feel it's like it's so
hear no evil see no evil see no evil
with the with the homeless you know I
mean it's like you you see him and you
wanna help or you feel like you should
help well how the hell do you help it's
like you just give money I mean the guy
was like yo man I get 50 Cent's and I
said just a second so I went inside I
bought my water
I had like seven dollars to water and I
got some gum and that was like five
dollars so I go outside and I go here
man
I give him the $2 whatever I had left he
goes hey this is more money than I asked
for brother
I'm like well now you want to have pride
him it's just weird you know but I'm
like I just you know Happy Thanksgiving
do you and he he says I can't I was like
you can't what I can't do me now I'm
like oh [ __ ] now I've gotten into her
I've gotten into a a philosophical
conversation with a homeless dude
outside of Chevron at midnight so I'm
like well do the best you can do that's
what I'm doing he said and my sick voice
is perfect cuz that's the voice he had
he was like just like that I'm doing the
best I can
brother I am doing the best I can I'm
out here and I'm like oh [ __ ] so I just
leave but it's just like damn there
everywhere there's tents everywhere like
what are we doing
it's like that's the cause we should be
like looking looking into I just I don't
know what to say guys the homeless
situation is so crazy right now and look
at me I'm talking about buying our
expensive ass car and all you know going
into clipper games and I'm like
and we are here with all these homeless
that's why I don't want to hear people
talking about animals yes
animals are important and I'm glad there
are upper middle-class rich mostly white
people that care about that because
without those people all the animals
will be dead
let's just be real they'd be dead right
but my thing is like I love your cause
but if you can't walk through like poor
neighborhoods walking door-to-door
talking about your cause if you can't do
that then you might need to re-evaluate
the importance of your cause or what I
mean to say it's like keeping it in
perspective okay keep it here if you
can't go down to the ghetto and not
gonna door and be like hi can I talk to
you about giraffes you know it's like
[ __ ] got real-life human
problems to deal with and you want to do
you know go door-to-door talking about
what we gonna do about these
disenfranchised people but look I don't
know I don't got the answers so anyway
there's our guy so I getting my back to
my first world problem sorry you know I
get in my car and I'm like so I finally
got it like charged so I realized I
gotta have the charger at my place but I
just the electric car is finally at a
place where it's dope you know what I
mean it's nice excuse me [ __ ] I was
gonna get out E or this Jaguar because I
didn't want to test like cuz everybody
got a Tesla but what I will say about
the Tesla is at least the infrastructure
is better it's more intact but I don't
appreciate that like if you have a Tesla
they got all these Tesla die Tesla has a
proprietary its own charging like plug
and I think that's [ __ ]
I think that's [ __ ] it's like you
know don't tell me you care about the
environment don't tell me that like this
is you know we're trying to do our part
for society and you have a money-making
system you know like this is your only
your thing it's like damn
it sucks and those things are everywhere
those Tesla supercharger stations are
everywhere and like if you have a
different type of car you can't use them
and I think that's [ __ ] up but
whatever that's just my opinion
but they have you know you think there's
charges everywhere but anyways the
electric cars looking dope right now me
my car I love how it looks leaking our
big tires and then like even the Tesla's
but I saw that Tesla truck that [ __ ]
looks stupid I'm just it looked like a
big DeLorean like I don't know what that
design is about and the inside did thing
look like a kitchen counter like you
should be chopping onions in your car
that's what it looks like it's
ridiculous it looks it looks like a
kitchen or a bathroom like this should
be a bathroom sink on the passenger seat
but it does go 500 miles per charge I
just wonder how long it takes to charge
that that might be like a 24 hours to
get a full charge that's something to
think about so I don't know but it just
looks crazy I just think it looks crazy
I wouldn't want to see that on the roads
that the Tesla truck looks like like the
nonsense version of electric cars from
before where we were like I don't want
to try that why can't you make it look
dope so but there's a lot of choices so
but anyways that was my electric car
drama you know and guys like I say I'm
sick right now but I felt like I still
should do a show I thought I should do
an episode so here I am I want to talk
about Disney plus I got Disney Plus and
I love it you know my favorite thing
about Disney Plus is that you can watch
it like everybody in the house got
something that they love on Disney Plus
like my girl she loves like the Disney
movie so he watched tangled the other
night which is not bad actually but like
she won't sit and watch Avengers with me
but you know you got the Marvel stuff
and then you got like the Disney movies
you got two Pixar movies but I don't
understand why all the movies aren't on
there like I noticed a
the second Avenger Avengers which will
infinity GWAR that one's not on Disney
Plus yet so that's kind of weird but
endgame is on there so like sometimes
and I don't know if I like the interface
like it's like hard to figure out like
where the movies are like you think they
should be in like some sort of
chronological order or like bite you
know sometimes you can't find them like
that like like you can see Iron Man but
you go where's Iron Man two and three
and by the way I don't even think Iron
Man 2 is on there like this weird
choices about what movies are on there
and what movies aren't on there but for
me I love all the Marvel stuff and I get
you know and I love all the old Disney
movies I like Beauty the B stand like a
lad in the original I got all those
original cartoons so Disney Plus has
been dope and of course the Mandalorian
who this
I love the Star Wars universe I think
they've like they've gone off the rails
you know cuz a lot of the movies are
just terrible you know I talked about it
with Bobby and and Steve on the podcast
before we talked about Star Wars and
it's just like some of these movies are
just not good or they don't live up to
the expectations or the hype of the
originals with Harrison Ford and you
know Mark Hamill and all that so the
movies are just you know if you think of
if you look at the totality of all the
movies they're not as good as we think
they are you know we got you know Star
Wars Empire and return the Jedi those
are the ones and then these other ones
you just kind of go when you look back
onto me like these aren't this good you
know with the Hayden Christensen ones
you know they just I don't know but I
like two rogue one I thought rogue one
was the better of these like new movies
so I love this universe that I like the
idea that they're gonna you know do
shows on Disney plus so this Mandalorian
is great like I it's amazing how much
you care about this character where we
don't even see this [ __ ] face I
don't even know what he looks like
you know and it's like you you care for
this like this you know this person's
world you can see that they are like the
world is in turmoil and like he's
trying to you know just take jobs
wherever he can even he's got honor and
pride and like you feel all this is just
oozing from the character and I did that
is great they're doing a great job with
that and then the music and then how it
looks and all that is great but the only
thing I don't like about it is like
there's like yeah I feel like there's
like 12 minutes of of credits and you
know ten minutes of you know recapping
the last episode and like eight minutes
a show you know it feels like that but
do I want 45 minutes of an mandalorian
as opposed to like the thirty I don't
know like how much show you actually get
maybe 20 minutes of show I don't know
but if they're gonna keep doing that
quality of show I hope they do it like
that I just don't know what's up with
this baby Yoda this baby yoader's we if
you're really deep into the Star Wars
universe like one of my buddies was
talking to me about this he was saying
like so this Yoda baby you I don't know
what the race is so do we call them
Yoda's Yoda was his name but that's not
his race but we'll just say that day you
know Yoda ease whatever so this little
baby Yoda is fifty years old and this is
four years after Return of the Jedi the
fall of the empire you know so that
means that just Yoda was alive during
all of that stuff make me Anakin
Skywalker wasn't actually the person
that's supposed to balance the force
maybe it was this kid this Yoda kid you
know what I mean maybe the Skywalker's
were just a bust you know it just didn't
work out for them and you know it's
really this so I don't know I don't know
how they're gonna tie the universes
together but I hope they you know keep
delving into like the different worlds
which all goes back to really what
Marvel did with the MCU the The Avengers
universe but Iron Man starting with Iron
Man they really changed how you look at
movies altogether like how you look at
like universes I mean because they made
all the universes together so now
brains work like that it's like Thor and
ant-man and all these all these movies
are all part of one big thing and you
could just make an infinite amount of
movies if you'd like you know we can you
know black panther we can go we can we
can Black Widow we can go see all these
characters and see their worlds you know
I mean I really love that and so that's
when Star Wars was like hey that's a
good idea that's when they made rogue
one and like all these other things so I
mean that's kind of cool so I hope they
keep doing that I'd like to see other
other things like that so that was
pretty cool
ah what else do I want to talk about
guys I don't know I do want to talk
about the issue of Bobby Lee and Andrew
Santino doing a podcast together so I'm
talking about this on my podcast you
know I really look guys this has all
been blown out of proportion it's really
not as serious as you think it is you
know Bobby and I had talked about doing
the podcast a long time ago he he
elected to do a podcast with his
girlfriend instead kalila and it's great
tiger belly is great Bobby is a
character they just work the balance
that she brings to it and Gilbert and
all the things that go on with their
podcast it just that [ __ ] works so you
know yes I was disappointed we joke
about it cuz like I wanted to do a
podcast too at the time I wish it I
would have just done my own like a back
then and so turns out Bobby didn't just
tell me he wanted to do a podcast with
me he actually told you Santino that a
long time ago too cuz Bobby's a [ __ ]
snake [ __ ] like that this he's
like makes promises to like a lot of
different people so that's what he did
this little piece of [ __ ] so he you know
so so now they have always thought about
this thing so now they're gonna do it
how do I feel about it I'm like yo I
wanted to do that but hey I'm doing my
own thing I've been doing my podcast now
for a year you know I when I I bring
multi s on all the time like multiple
times like every time I have Steve on
it's great you know we talked so I'm
gonna continue to do that you know it's
fine I'm really not like it's not like
I'm like you know oh my god
but that's what they put out there like
like that's what Bobby put out there to
like for the smoke and so then we've
been having fun with it behind the
scenes but then it gets kind of out of
hand the way you fans react to it cuz
the fans are all like you know oh man
come on groove it don't be a [ __ ] lift
them it's like I'm not stopping them
from doing anything they could do
whatever the hell they want so and they
probably are gonna do it and it's fine
and I'm still gonna do this I'm still
doing we're from a griffon SiC throat
couldn't do my wolves and I'm still out
here doing my podcast so you know I love
the the growth the experience I'm doing
this all on my own you know I'm trying
to just it's just me I'm trying to build
my own fan base I want you guys to
listen to me for me not because of who I
have on not because of who I'm
affiliated with or not because of who
you like you know it's just because you
like to see what I'm doing
so here I am so you know so anyways just
to squash the whole thing there is no
beef there is no problem they're gonna
do their thing and it's gonna be awesome
also like I doubt we're gonna the
Scorpion lashes was just a fun thing to
talk about I doubt that kilala and I
whatever like Willy do a podcast cuz she
has a lot to deal with on her own she's
dating Bobby like that that's a
full-time job you know I mean but you
know I'll have her come on I'll have
Angelo come on Bobby oh come on you know
they'll come on my podcast and we'll
just do we normally do so you know it's
fun times guys so but again there's no
beef it's all squashed it was all smoke
there was nothing real to it so there I
put that out there yes I did see the the
Lee family they had a documentary about
the Lee family it was called parasite
that [ __ ] movie was bananas I'm gonna
talk about that movie so many times on
this podcast that was like Korean excuse
me yeah and I'm leaving already I'm
leaving the cough saying [ __ ] it this is
raw um
the Korean movies dude are just so
they're so crazy like they're just I
didn't understand
was happening in this movie it was a
it's a great name because like what a
parasite does is what you know but it
just go you got to see this movie they
get used to the rainy I hate reading
movies but this movie was so engaging so
funny so creepy
but these Korean movies always have this
like weird twist well you're like you
thinking movies about this and then all
of a sudden and in this movie I had like
a super weird twist and then it just
ended up being like you know just a very
entertaining movie so but it did remind
me of like Steve was the skinny dude
Bobby was like the sister who was like
mean but it was good you guys should you
should check out parasite parasite was
one of them that's actually one of the
best movies I've seen this year I've
seen some weird movies I saw that Will
Smith movie what was it called god I
don't even look it up see what just Will
Smith movie I just saw but it was like
like we love Will Smith right like this
dude he's made so many movies what was
the name of it man Oh Gemini man yeah
the Gemini man so I saw Gemini man and
the technology was amazing it's that
de-aging stuff and they're doing that a
lot because I think they did that also
in irishman so I just watched irishman
on Netflix and shout out to my boys
Sebastian Maniscalco who was you know he
was he was a good character cuz I hated
him in the movie like I wanted him to
die you know I mean so that means he was
doing a good job but I didn't realize it
the movie was about Jimmy Hoffa and all
that stuff that was going on and I don't
know it just it was okay it's on Netflix
so if you got Netflix just watch it but
it's just you know mob violence that's
like Scorsese's you know that's his
little thing that he does I'd love to
see him make like a kids movie or just
make a sci-fi
movie or make I'd like to see him make a
movie that you know it's not about the
same thing or the same the same use of
that world but you know that's his thing
but it was like it was just okay to me
but I'd recommend watching it you know
you might love it or you might be like
yeah it was whatever but they used the
de-aging because they made De Niro and
Pacino and everybody looked really I was
like wow this is amazing and it's just a
weird to the eyes I don't know if you
guys watched it d aging it does
something weird cuz I can Gemini man it
was cool but I watched it and some kind
of like super age like the eight like
you know 4k I watched it in on an 8k
theater I think it's called a K I'm not
sure but I think it's called a K so it
was like super crisp so that also like
highlighted the CGI of it now like
there's this scene at the end of the
movie where Will Smith is walking there
the two Will Smith's are walking next to
each other and then it started to look
really bizarre and you really start but
I think that was because of watching it
in this like high-definition 8k or 6k
whatever it is but if you would have
watched it like in a regular movie it
might have looked amazing but it was
cool it's just like the story sucked
this just destroy wasn't it wasn't it
didn't grab you and that's my problem
with a lot of movies I've been watching
right now they just don't grab you you
know like they're like flashy and
everything looks great but there's
something missing from it man I don't
know scuse me I had a previous argument
on the podcast about like with Steve you
know because people can send me messages
about it like you know Scorsese
how he made that comment about the
Marvel movies and to me this is what
Scorsese does is he uses mob of violence
like his the mob of violence is the same
thing as superhero whatever the
superhero thing is it's equivalent you
know and
when I look back on the Marvel movies
cuz I've been catching up again on the
Disney Plus Robert Downey jr. is
fantastic like he don't get enough
credit for what a great actor he is
I got believed this [ __ ] has
Iron Man like Oh like in endgame when he
gets back to the Avengers he's all
skinny and you know the things he was
saying to Captain America you know what
I mean like you know your precious
freedoms and that whole speech he gave
was like they made like this dis
fantastical universe so grounded and
believable and I think they should get
credit for that I think it was freaking
amazing along with being like a
fantastic ride a fun rollercoaster but
when you look at like these Scorsese
films which I love by the way don't get
me wrong I love it but it's the there's
a trick there to you know it's just kind
of like Goomba you know Italian mafia
you know and it's always like you know
killing and there's always somebody you
know the higher-ups and there's always
somebody in all those movies at the
higher-ups end up killing somebody and
it's all this you know he's using the
same kind of his own tricks so you know
I just think they you know I don't think
you should criticize the the Marvel
movies the ways doing you know I mean I
just I don't like that
but you guys don't care I'm thinking
about making a Christmas album and I
actually have some great Christmas I'm
not gonna play all of the song for you
guys right now except but I do want to
tease it so you guys can see what I got
in the mix this was pretty dope this is
what I got in the mix from our Christmas
from some Christmas songs you don't love
this man
Oh what's up y'all
[Music]
I wish my voice wasn't messed up [ __ ] it
get on that's why I get my boy Rick
Atari fantastic platinum with producer
he hit me up randomly and was like yo
man I listen to your podcast I want to
make it some hard you wanna do Christmas
album so he sent me like three dope
beats my buddy Ben who's gonna be on the
podcast he made me a Christmas song and
then the dudes from detective design
dope apart those guys they made me like
you know so I saw two so I might have
like a five or six song EP Christmas EP
coming out for y'all so be ready for
that here on rhythm with Griffin I've
done the podcast now for a year and I
don't know I don't know like am i doing
good it's hard to tell you know it's
hard to be out here doing the podcast
and then seeing other people who are my
peers you know comedic ly like you know
people that I'm saying I I've been doing
comedy with for like ten years now some
of them have gone on to be like
multi-millionaire superstars you know
like Chris D'Elia you know some of them
are like you know now you like look good
feel isn't another guy who like five
years ago I was doing his podcast and it
was nothing I'm saying like nothing like
like he was struggling along and then
POW superstardom rocket launcher you
know I mean so it's like so when I see
that kind of stuff in the podcast I
started my podcast I'm like and Tiger
Bailey to talk about Bobby there is
huge podcast so I'm sitting here I'm
like wow I want mine to be big like that
because you know I'm playing catch-up so
it's hard to like stay focused on your
journey when you see the success of the
people around you that's just a hard
thing to manage you know but that's the
whole thing about this business is like
you have to like manage your
expectations manage your disappointments
and like you know just you know I mean
so that's what I'm doing right now so
when I look back on it I go alright this
is cool it's modest I'm enjoying it you
know I'm making a little bit of money
but it's like I get to talk to like
people and then you know people that
I've known for a little while that I
didn't know a lot of these things about
them I'm just learning so many things
about you know people that come on and I
got some good guests coming up I'm gonna
have Dane Cook on again I want to have
Dane on again because I feel like Dane
has been on like a weird and apology
tour like every podcast he goes on
people are like they're like hey Dana
you you know you were you were an
[ __ ] and now you're not an [ __ ] or
like why were you acting like that or
you know that kind of [ __ ] like so they
were like you know you were bumping
people they were just didn't putting him
on trial like everybody puts a guy on
trial and he is credit he answered every
question and he like put himself out
there you know I don't know if he was
like completely honest with us and but I
just feel like he did the best he could
in that situation then he told the story
of his brother II you know he told us so
many times like he told him on other
podcast that like um your mom's house he
told her that that clip alone has
million of hits you know I mean so like
he's out there doing his thing
but I think that he wants to come on a
podcast and just have fun and laugh and
like talk about nonsense the way we all
do on normal podcast so I want to have
him on again and just talk about video
games and just talk about you know
what's going on in the world and you
know I mean just give him an opportunity
just to be a funny guy again
you know so I think he deserves that you
know so we'll see how that goes
you know so I can say I look back on I
saw that he's coming on
I got Anthony Jeselnik coming on I mean
he's dead guys he's just funny good so I
can't wait to have him on I'm gonna have
her Christina come on who else is coming
on I got I gotta I'm gonna have Deon
Cole I got a lot of people you know
coming up you know so I can I want to
get to my hundredth episode in style
right you know it's uh it's been it's
been quite a ride you know I mean I love
all the things that people send me you
know I got like the other stuff that
people send me it's just like it's
incredible how how connected you feel
with the fans you know or you know I
didn't realize how many people are out
there just listening to podcast you guys
are just out here like hey you know I
work eight hours a day and I need to
like listen to something I don't even
realize what a market it is and I'm so
sorry I'm so sick right now I'm like you
know you guys are my hasta que I'm like
sweating right now coughing my throat is
killing me and I gotta go do shows
tomorrow but I was like [ __ ] this I
still got to put out an episode of the
podcast you know what I mean so here I
am doing it it's hard though because
like I say it's like 1:30 in the morning
right now you know freaking Thursday
9:00 the day of Thanksgiving and Here I
am doing a podcast I got clipper tickets
again I broke down
I found a buddy who going with me cuz
Adam our tickets I was had tickets with
Adam but like you know now the Clippers
are great and he's not going out of town
finally so I think he just wants to go
he's getting married so he's gonna go
with his girl all the time and you know
he's gonna do it like that and so I was
like ah you know I don't know if I had
the money I was like let me let me take
a break but then like some tickets
opened up and Here I am I got some
clipper tickets
so I got another buddy something will
start going back I love what they're
doing I just don't know about this damn
load management that Kawhi Leonard is
doing I don't know is he I feel like he
has a more serious injury than their
lead and not letting on that could be
the situation because he had I read that
he had a degenerative me disease and I
looked that up because I'm not a doctor
and I don't play one on TV
and it's like an arthritis arthritic
condition that excuse me that doesn't
get better I think that's one of these
conditions that like it will you know
like the more wear and tear you have on
it in the knee the rubbing the harder
discs to like you know keep doing that
and recover with the swelling and all
this kind of stuff so he has to take
rest so that tells me then that he can't
play three four or five games in seven
eight nine days during the playoffs
because last year when he won the
championship he progressively got worse
in the playoffs because he had to play
all the time and like let's say klay
Thompson doesn't get hurt
let's say Cameron Garnett doesn't get
hurt and Golden State goes on to win a
championship what then would we be
saying about Kawhi Leonard it might be
that you know how you ain't out of gas
or easy that injury is something but
because he won the championship we kind
of just push it under the rug and don't
even think about it but there might be
something seriously wrong with him I
hope not
or I hope we get the best out of it this
year because can you even a make the
Clippers just even being in the Western
Conference final is like amazing I've
lived in LA my whole life I used to go
to the Clipper games back in the day I
used to go like when you know Terry the
hair Kent Norman and all those guys were
playing Lloyd Vaught you know I used to
go back then when they played at the
Sports Center the Sports Arena I'm
saying little [ __ ] arena downtown and
it's like now they're you know when we
went through the Blake Griffin Chris
Paul DeAndre Jordan
stuff was going on it was like oh man
look this is incredible cuz you know we
really thought we could win and then we
just didn't win but that was like
incredible it changed the whole
narrative of what the Clippers are now
we're in a situation we're like we're
literally one of the best teams in the
league like two or three like the Lakers
- Clippers and I don't know who else but
like the Clippers are like favored to
win the championship like that would be
freaking amazing if the Clippers won the
championship or even just got to like
that level of play I don't even know
just as the LA sports fan and I never
was a Laker oh I wasn't a big Laker guy
I don't know why I just didn't like I
liked Shaq I was a big fan of Shaq I
still AM I think he's hilarious I love
him on that show at Charles Barkley and
Kenny you know on TNT um I was a big fan
of Shaq so I enjoyed that era but I also
have my Kobe hater
so I didn't like Kobe Bryant I just I
just thought I loved hating Kobe Bryant
it's just fun to hate him you know he's
so good but it's fun to hate a guy like
that just his personality and everything
so I never really liked the Lakers but
it was hard to like support the Clippers
because there was some dark there was
some dark years with the Clippers man so
like when we got Blake Griffin like
Blake Griffin was the one that changed
the narrative of the Clippers he's in
one that like we had the number one pick
and he was like a top 10 player you know
he was like exciting and Duncan and all
that stuff that he was doing then he
gets hurt but when we got Chris Paul it
was like oh man
this is it right but we just never got
over the hump so to where we are now
it's like damn it's amazing but anyways
I guess to finish up you know I hope you
guys had a really great Thanksgiving you
know the holidays like such weird times
because we're supposed to like sit
around with people that we barely hang
out with you know we're supposedly blood
relatives so that's that means that
we're supposed to act a certain way but
like do like who really
Aires because when you're there and
you're looking at them you're like I
like this person or it's just weird like
in Thanksgiving is one of those days
were like gasps we're supposed to
remember what we're thankful for
I hope you guys did that I guess I'm
thankful so I guess I'll talk about the
things that I'm thankful you know I'm
thankful that I still have a career i
thankful that like you know I'm still
doing it you know that when I decided to
go into comedy and acting and for me to
still be doing it today is like it's
pretty amazing to me so I'm thankful for
that I'm thankful that my mom is still
kicking even with this you know disease
it's dementia stuff but I'm glad that
her personality is still intact and I'm
thankful for that every single day so
I'm trying to spend as much time with
her as I can I'm thankful for my step
dad my stepdad he you know you know I
don't you know it's like if you let me
give you some advice out there if you're
our only child or or if you just you
have a single parent even if you have
brothers and sisters you have a single
parent okay
don't be possessive of your parent
especially your mom let your mom go out
date and meet people and live a lot live
her old life because trust me you want
her to have her own life and be happy
you want somebody to look after her and
take care of her because you're gonna
want to live your life like if my
stepfather wasn't around and then my mom
was by herself I don't know what [ __ ]
I'd be doing right now I don't even know
if I would have had the same career
because I would have had to worry about
her and making sure she's okay and like
I just it's just let your mom guys if
you're out there single moms if you're
you know if you're like don't be that
kid just like you you know you ain't my
dad or or look you don't have to have a
relationship with this guy y'all don't
gotta be buddy-buddy okay cuz my
stepfather and I we're not buddy-buddy
but there's a respect there like I
really appreciate this guy and if
something were to happen to my mom like
I'm all-in making sure that my
stepfather is okay
like that's how much I appreciate him
and so I'm telling you as advice as an
older guy if you're young right now and
see your mom you know she's dating some
guy you're kind of like what's going on
that's my mom just remember your mom
deserves her own life she's done a lot
to get you to the point you're at right
now
to it to be resentful in like the reason
why you're so possessive is because of
how great she is so let her go on and
have her own thing so I'm thankful for
that you know I'm thankful for being
like at the comp II store right now at
this time you know what I think we're
gonna look back at this era and it's
gonna be like era where you're like damn
this is great like you know Joe Rogan
what he's doing you know what Joe Rogan
and friends and like it's always packed
and like you know he's bringing more
people to the store because of his
podcast and his his presence and curse
you know Chris D'Elia is like just
watching him become a superstar CEO Ali
Wong Neal Brennan like all the guys that
are there right now Joey Diaz
Tony hitch cliff it's like we're all
like at a part of this this magical time
in the store that like you know in ten
years they're gonna lie I'm glad to know
I couldn't say that I was a part of that
so when you list off the comics you know
in ten 20 years when you list off the
comics that was oh man this is when the
Comedy Store was like in a great new
heyday they're gonna have to say my name
so I'm thankful for that that's pretty
cool
you know what I mean um what else am i
thankful for I guess acting I know
somebody's put in the comments like
don't talk about your girlfriend but I
gotta be thankful for my girlfriend to
you know we had broken up we got back
together and we're at a place right now
that is like wow it's just beautiful you
know I died I truly love her and so you
know she's the one y'all so don't be
surprised if Danny proposes I'm the one
saying it on my podcast I guess I reveal
too much on this [ __ ] you know you guys
don't deserve to know everything but I
guess that's what you do you just all in
here and you just talk so I'm thankful
for you guys that's an that that's the
last thing I'm
before I'm super thankful for the loyal
fans even if it's a small number of you
guys I just I appreciate it when people
walk up to me on the street and they're
like yo man removal Griffin I'm like oh
[ __ ] you know like that's that's great
cuz a lot of times it's like workaholics
Montez you know older people are like oh
man I'm dying up here I'm Dinah Pitt was
great
you know but when people come up to me
now and they're just like yo man I love
riffing with Griffin
you know the people do woo-woos when
they see me whoa whoa hey man my [ __ ]
voice my sick woo-woos yeah I got some
sick what's going on you know so I thank
you for that it makes me feel like I'm
doing something good I mean this is a
lot man I'm just a [ __ ] full time job
you know what I mean like nobody's
nobody's making me do this I have to do
this on my own
you know I mean and if you want to start
a podcast that's what you have to
understand that like it is a commitment
you have to put in work you have to
sacrifice you have to do it when you're
sick or not it schedule you get I mean
just everything you have to do to make
your podcast work get your content out
there and you know just somebody you
latch onto it and or you know or not but
you have to really the people listening
have to know that you care about it that
you know this is a big deal look I got a
whole room in my place that I've turned
into like you know just for this you
know I mean so let me see and I also got
some I got some more art I haven't put
this one up yet but I got this one this
Riverwood Griffin and this is from my
shoe game sighs I don't know well here's
his information back here but check that
out so I got that with what Griffin
let's see what is his name again
Oh could I rice si Dai rice my shoe game
is to okay yeah it is my shoe game is to
the number 2's I see see my shoe game is
to I don't know
it may be I'm too old to understand this
but this is kind of nice right had to
find off a spot for that what if the
candle lit this on fire to just they'll
be a nightmare and I used to sell a
t-shirt so I got this framed a long time
ago but I used to tell us I used to sell
it I had this joke about [ __ ]
so I still have this t-shirt I have it
in there wait so I went on upside down
Oh anyway this is [ __ ] and it was like
all the different names people call it
and I have it on there the JJ snatch
sausage beater Pandora's box
roast beef curtains dick destroyer
trouble tunnel bearded clam salami slot
papaya pink raccoon there's a lot of
names here salmon taco haha he's a
stupid Republic of labia so I need to
bring this one after Woodworks again of
course the fish that's the old fish
picture so I put that one up it's like a
mix things up but just for the record
these are fake I did I did a movie and
like my character they made this and it
was so amazing that I was like dear can
I have that I mean it just it looks real
you know what I mean it looks like I
[ __ ] thought anyways this may not be
the greatest episode ever but I just
wanted to do another episode because you
know I mean like this show must go on
but I guess I have some good guests
coming in the next couple weeks I'm
booked so I'm gonna have you know all
these great people coming in crystally
look I say Anthony just one egg Deon
Cole all those people are coming in I'm
gonna try to get the Christmas album
going I have been come in he has his own
podcast now Kyle my podcast with Ben I
talking about band a lot on the show
because you just like such a character
in my life so I got to have these weirdo
characters come back onto the podcasts
have like a family moment you know what
I mean these are people are considered
family because I'm an only child so I
don't have brothers and sisters and I'm
not really close to my blood family so
you have to like get your chosen family
those are some of the best people in
your life so I got to have those people
back on again like I haven't had Cody on
in a while either Healy early early
early perhaps I had my I cover my hot
gay friend a good gay news you know just
like entertainment news and stuff like
that so I got to get him back on again
too because sometimes people ask about
it hey whatever happened to that guy so
that guy will be on to so but anyways
guys this is a weird little solo episode
of her former girlfriend called the sick
episode I just needed to get an episode
out and had a few things on my mind and
I wanted to talk to you guys about it
but like I say I appreciate you
listening
terrific Irfan you know we need we need
to do is we need to just go out we need
to go out on our regular our regular
theme song so where is it here we go
so ladies and gentlemen thank you for
listening
- your favorite podcast you know the
night y'all I'll see you next week
but thanks for listening as usual
[Music]